hi Joe how are you I can see the
frustration in your eyes when you say
what are we expecting from the Arab
League let me put it this way you don't
expect a lot because we have to figure
out the right reason for the taller
ladies division of the Arab world the
first thing I would like to tell you is
that they are about the whole Arab world
has to rearrange their priorities what
are our priorities is our priority in
the media finding the next superstar of
the other bones that's not our priority
our priority is to focus on you and the
youth you are the future of tomorrow so
if you invest in you and give you the
right resources and put your energy in
the right place they will have a better
of a better tomorrow the second thing is
what you expect from the Arab League is
basically to to talk to us and
communicate with us we have all seen in
the last few years they are leaders they
meet on a regular basis but what the
results are we getting as people out of
that is not a lot i just read in the
newspaper that Carlos gosselin is
talking about opening the Arab countries
economy together and he opened to Nissan
has to manufacturing facilities in egypt
and morocco and ironic enough that he
cannot export from Egypt other of the
Arab world so we have to look into the
solution and the next generation let me
give you another example the investors
and venture capitals I am Anna to the
northern I go and pitch my ideas to them
they always say give us any ideas like
facebook youtube google and my answer to
them and to you and you have this as an
advice from me it's basically we will
never end our world get the facebook and
google idea and tell we set up the right
priorities second we invest and to the
basics so facebook did not come into
untapped economy the american economy
was ready to incubate such an idea but
in the art world there are so many end
tab and gaps in many industries name it
and the financial industry and education
and the health care and advertising in a
PR and many other industries so the
solution has to be at the core of the
problem and not just looking at the
solution as a broad what you can do i'll
just give you one piece of advice
believe in what you do even if you
cannot see it and work from your heart
and like my mother always tells me when
you go to work take your heart with you
because anyways you're going to work
work from your heart so if every other
person work from his heart for the right
reason no matter if he was an office
porn or who has a chairman we will do a
change and trust me as much as you are
frustrated I am frustrated but we cannot
just sit and say we are frustrated a lot
of leaders are not doing anything to us
because they will throw the ball on us
and with another poll on them let us do
our job it has worked together as you
and wait for tomorrow because trust me
if you were from your heart tomorrow
will come in a much better in a much
better situation the third thing that I
would like to say I hope you know today
and be World Economic Forum there will
be tangible results and I am wondering
where as the richest are a person he has
to be here he has to look into
opportunities not only in singers and
media because at the end of the day as I
mentioned the beginning priorities as as
the next thing that everyone inaudible
task talked about and not again I'm up
against singers but they are not our
priorities thank you